which i mean were you doing [ __ ] at a
young age
your dad's in a suit and tie and you're
like jumping off cliffs and
you know i mean a little bit sure i mean
uh
i i heard a story about uh
me as a toddler you know not even
walking i don't think
and they said there was like climbing
out of a window on some like
15-story you know
apartment or something um
yeah i was definitely acting like an
[ __ ]
from a very early age and and
my over-developed need for attention
was uh prominent
you know out of the gate so i've always
been an attention [ __ ]
and um you know and at whatever age
there was always just something
that uh that i was acting out with did
you feel like it was uh because you know
with me i i can relate i always wanted
to make my father laugh i always wanted
him to like accept me i always wanted
and my dad was very corporate work you
know six to five or six every night and
you know
i think i was sort of like my mom in a
way where i was kind of all over the
place
the short attention span didn't know
what the hell i was doing wasn't good in
school
started you know acting and things like
that and just
i think he just kind of looked at me
like [ __ ] this son i guess the next
sun's gonna be better and
you know my brother brother was smarter
and they got along better in fact my mom
once was
she i remember saying oh mark to my dad
i know eric's your favorite we all know
eric's your favorite
in front of me and i'm like jesus i mean
i knew it but to hear my mother say it
so what i'm saying is i always was like
i couldn't it wasn't enough
and i felt like i was always trying to
get attention from other people from
whatever to
because i didn't get that attention with
my dad do you think that there was part
of that
is eric an older brother eric is my
younger brother he's he's the smarter
one yeah he's uh he's like six years
younger
so i think that to me is an indication
that that neither of your parents are
alcoholic
is that right that's actually you know
my mom was sort of a pill popper a
little bit my dad really never drank but
he was extremely strict you know even
though he did a bunch of [ __ ] which i
didn't know
i mean if you like you would have been
in prison like
my dad if it was you because he i i
remember i got my ear pierced by the
next door neighbor and i looked at him
with my opposite ear and i go hey
what would you think i've ever got my
ear pierced he goes you'd go to a
halfway house is what you do
i go oh see well i'm going to be at
nate's next door for the next week till
this heals
you know what i mean so like so was your
father like that was he strict was he
did you feel like he needed to act out
or well yeah i mean
my whole family dynamic is uh it really
explains everything
um i'd say you know take it
uh you know sort of one piece at a time
yes my dad was strict and he was a a
corporate executive but his job
um involved a great deal of travel so he
was
almost not there more than he was there
and so it was a very inconsistent like
if dad was around he would try to kind
of uh compensate for the time he was
gone by being more of a disciplinarian i
i think
you know and so it was just like dad's
not here i can do whatever
dad's here oh you know it's sort of an
inconsistent thing
and um as far as the family dynamic goes
my dad uh was actually sort of the black
sheep of his family
for choosing a career in business
he came from just a long
line of academic scholars
theologians clergymen zoologists
you know like he was uh it was very
very like incredibly academic
and and lower earning uh lineage that my
dad came from
you know he grew up with with
very little money but just a lot of
prestige you know all this uh
scholastic kind of kind of thing and
then and uh you know
his dad was a published author and a
zoologist and
had a decorated uh you know army
colonel um all this very very respected
family and then dad's gonna go into
business and that was like all right
well that's not what i would have chosen
for you son you know
um and then on my mom's side of the
family it's
all alcoholism you know
gambling suicide like addiction like
just really really dark uh you know
addiction stuff
and um the way that that works
i i have an older sister i'm the second
of two children
and um it's sort of a cookie cutter kind
of a deal
that when you have uh an and as
an absentee alcoholic parent that
the first child will will really over
achieve you know it's like wow i'm not
being noticed you know like i've got
like my parents have other stuff going
on they're not paying attention to me
to try to get noticed i'm going to over
achieve i'm going to get straight a's
look at me i'm perfect you know is that
enough for you and uh
and i think that that's that's a pretty
regular sort of stereotype that really
applies to my situation
where i have this overachieving older
sister and then i come into the picture
you know there's not a lot of attention
being doled out by either parents
because dad's gone and mom's drunk
and my sister is this perfect straight a
character
doing everything right and you know the
second child comes along and looks at
the efforts of the older child and says
wow there is no [ __ ] way i can
compete with that